as president Trump continues to hammer
the failed liberal policies that wrecked
Baltimore some Democrat strongholds are
still pushing policies that treat school
kids like well they're just social
justice lab rats
just yesterday New York City officials
approved a new get this culturally
responsive education policy that
requires schools to stop the practices
that lead to predictable outcomes of
success or failure for historically
marginalized students despite the fact
that most NYC students aren't proficient
in reading or math now here to make
sense of all this is Dinesh D'Souza a
conservative author filmmaker Dinesh
when you dig down about what culturally
responsive education means you find out
that it's the same liberal educative
that's been confusing students and
keeping them stuck for decades now yeah
it's not really education at all it's
the politics of victimology the idea
here is to reconcile minority students
to their poor performance and instead of
trying to improve the performance to
locate a person to blame for it namely
the system or the white man so this is
actually a recipe for it's not a recipe
for creating educated students it's not
a recipe for preparing you to balance a
checkbook or get a job or start a
business it might be a recipe if you
want to go to work for an tyfa or black
lives matter but it limits your
occupational choices really to those two
categories all right well here's the
proficiency chart for New York City
Dinesh now check it out math well you
see grade four twenty six percent are at
or above proficient grade eight goes up
to a whopping twenty seven percent
reading twenty six grade eight twenty
seven science Wow
grade four only 18% of proficient or
above grade eight thirteen percent yet I
just want to keep going back to
culturally responsive because this
reminds me of you know back in our alma
mater in the 80s it started you started
this start concept started trickling in
back then this is what it says it said
that the one-page definition of cultural
responsive says students vary
perspectives whether tied to nationality
religion race or other backgrounds
should be seen as essential assets
it also requires schools to quote foster
critical consciousness dinesh about
historical and contemporary forms of
bias and suppression that's the
definition of culturally responsible
which means the Chinese students they're
yours protested at a meeting because
they're like wait we don't get
translators while the Spanish kids
getting translators we're not getting
translators so everybody's at each
other's throat now yeah this is you know
the New York Public Schools are among
the most diverse in the world you don't
have to teach the kids about diversity
they are diverse this would be like
having a program to teach me about being
Indian you don't need to do that the
broader meaning of this I think is quite
startling you know Trump attack these
Democratic Party run cities as being
crime-infested drug infested rat
infested but I think he in a way
understated the case if I were a poor
kid in a slum I would rather choose to
be in a slum in Mumbai or in one of the
favelas in Brazil than in Baltimore or
New York City now why is that because
even in Mumbai I get a good education
I have a strong intact family if you
transplant me out of poverty and put me
into a place why I have opportunity I
can thrive the problem for the poor kids
in Baltimore and New York is they're not
even being prepared with the basic
skills for life so even if opportunity
comes their way they don't know what to
do with it they don't have the ability
to perform at the jobs that they're not
being educated for so this is a real
disaster in the making so we're teaching
them to be professional agitators or
community activists or protesters are
members of whatever you know group
happens to be vogue at the moment but
we're not really giving them the skills
in science or math or writing that would
actually make them more productive and
probably make more money in society
detention by the way the president got a
lot of heat because there was a tweet he
sent out about Elijah Cummings the
robbery of his home really bad news is
and Baltimore House of Cummings was
robbed too bad today he said that well
that wasn't a wisecrack he said I was
you know I just basically reported what
was in the news so the media hopped on
that and pestered him about that at his
helicopter spray today and he said I was
just basically repeating what everyone
else had said but they're not letting
this Cummings Elijah Cummings things go
well I think you know Trump's thing was
taken as being a kind of snarky a
chuckle at Cummings estate but there's a
broader point here and that is that
usually these politicians can pursue
these policies that make life miserable
for other people make these
neighborhoods extremely dangerous but
they themselves live in gated
communities where they're immune from
the consequences of their own policies
Nancy Pelosi I'm sure doesn't have to
live with homeless people at her door in
San Francisco for example and generally
neither would Elijah Cummings so I think
this is actually kind of an interesting
case where the crime in Baltimore
actually found its way to Elijah
Cummings his own door thanks to Nash
great to see you tonight